[Music]
it's been five years since for a games
last journeyed into the subterranea of
post-apocalyptic Moscow with Metro last
lights but soon the next chapter of
Artyom story will be told when Metro
Exodus emerges in February as the title
suggests excellest will take players far
beyond the confines of the
claustrophobic metro system and across
the vast unforgiving Russian landscape
on a year-long journey to Vladivostok
with a five-year production time between
games you'll be forgiven for needing a
quick refresher on the story so allow us
to bring you up to speed at speed it's
2033 and the world has been ravaged by a
global nuclear holocaust in Russia's
capital Moscow survivors have retreated
to the underground metro system and
formed new communities and rival
factions life is hard especially as
their new home is also populated by
bloodthirsty mutants young Artyom's life
is forever changed when he's asked to
travel far from his home to polish at
the heart of the Metro to issue a
warning the dark ones are coming the
dark one suspected to be the next
evolution of mankind apparently cause
humans to suffer fatal hallucinations
but not Artyom this quark catches the
eye of this guy bourbon he teams up with
Artyom and teaches him survival lessons
on route to his next destination DRI
station there bourbon is almost
immediately killed by the leader of a
bandit faction this is not one of the
survival lessons down a friend Artyom
gets a new one con he's a member of the
Spartan Rangers were exactly the guys
our team's tried to warn about the Dark
One's together they journey to polish
fighting through the Communist redline
the Nazi 4th Reich and even sentient
electric bulbs Artyom finally reaches
PI's and finds his target Miller head of
the Spartan Rangers Miller agrees that
the Dark One's are a threat the Polish
council not so much
Miller helps anyway and directs Artyom
to d6 a nuclear missile launch facility
that could once again scorch Moscow and
all the Dark One's with it
one problem nobody knows where it is
Artyom goes to the library a huge
archive full of librarians not the
bookish shashi kind but massive
intelligent music gorillas who love a
good stare down Artyom finally looks
enough of them in the eye to locate the
directions to d6
the last leg of this exhausting Odyssey
has our team extracting nuclear fuel
rods from a giant sagging flesh pile
called the biomass climbing to 540
tall Austin Kino broadcast tower and
being trapped in his own
subconsciousness by the dark ones
nobody said wiping out an entire species
was easy but Artyom persists and
successfully rains their nuclear fire on
the dark ones which is a pity because it
turns out they just wanted to be friends
a year later and word reaches Artyom of
a surviving Dark One can't think said
the key t manatee survival Miller
doesn't he tells our team to find and
kill the dark one with the help of
master sniper and his daughter Anna
Artyom finds the dark one but that's
just a kid they're both captured by the
Nazi Reich and separated but Artyom is
quickly rescued by Pavel more Azov a red
line grunts the pair form a close bond
until twist
Pavel reveals is actually a high-ranking
Red Line officer together with Red Line
general Corbett and treacherous Spartan
Ranger Lissitzky
he plans to take d6 by force tortured
and facing execution Artyom is saved by
a Leonid Musquin son of the red lines
leader he escapes and battles his way to
octobrush kya station where he discovers
a terrible secret the red line plans to
infect stations with a powerful strain
of the Ebola virus stolen from d6 and
then murdered the survivors until
they're the only remaining faction
Artyom reunites with and romances Ana
goes on a surreal Vision Quest with Khan
and resolves to protect the young Dark
One throughout this there are two major
revelations young Artyom is not only the
reason mutants got into the metro but
also the first person to meet a Dark One
one thrilling train rescue later and
Artyom and the dark one child are back
on the road to Polly's once there they
interrupt to peace settlements between
the major feuding factions to drop some
bombs truth not nuclear for once the red
lines leader is psychically coerced into
revealing their diabolical scheme and
all hell breaks loose
general Corbett smashes an armored train
straight into Artyom and the Rangers and
all hope appears to be lost
but then just as an injured our team is
about to self-destruct c6 a whole group
of Dark One's arrive in the nick of time
and wipe out the red line the young Dark
One and his fellow survivors bid our
team a fond farewell and promise to one
day return which brings us to the end of
our team story so far a story that will
continue
in Metro Exodus what we know is that
it's set to years after the events of
last lights and that Artyom and Anna are
now traveling cross-country along the
trans-siberian railway
why have they abandoned Metro what new
dangers will they face all will no doubt
be revealed when Metro Exodus launches
February 15 2019
[Music]